I think I probably have a much higher IQ
than you do I suspect I went to law
school on a full academic scholarship
the only one in my in my class I'd have
a full academic scholarship in the first
year in law school I decided I didn't
want to be in law school and ended up in
the bottom two-thirds of my class and
then decided I wanted to stay went back
to law school and in fact ended up in
the top half of my class I won the
international moot Court competition I
was the outstanding student in the
political science department at the end
of my year I graduated with three
degrees from undergraduate school and
165 credits only need 123 credits and
I'd be delighted to sit down and compare
my IQ to yours if you'd like Frank
yeah I think I now concede he did not
graduate in the top half of his law
school class that he does not have three
degrees from college and that he was not
named outstanding political science
student in college Newsweek says Biden
actually went to school on a half
scholarship ended up near the bottom of
his class and won only one degree not
three Joe Biden ranked 76th in a class
of 85 at the University of Syracuse law
school I mean this guy comes off this
whole thing as a flyweight now Biden
says Newsweek is right his memory had
failed him
foreign
Rubin this is the Reuben report it's
January 19th 2023 and fear or not my
memory will not fail me we are live
streaming on Rumble and YouTube
subscribe if you have not and as you
know
we've got a live post game show after
every show now over at
reubenreport.locals.com I really thought
that was just like the perfect cold open
we're not even going to be heavy hitting
on uh old Joe today but when I saw that
video this morning I was just like it's
just so perfect it's just so everything
the smugness his dismissiveness to the
guy asking the question and then of
course it all turns out to be lies and
as you guys know although they rarely
talk about mainstream media Joe Biden
also had to get out of running for
president I think in 1988 when it turned
out that he was plagiarizing speeches
but somehow he is the president of the
United States these days and uh God help
us all anyway we are going to be doing a
little continuation of what we've been
doing all week you know I've been
hitting the world economic Forum clowns
pretty pretty hard I was actually at a
party last night and a couple people
came up to me and said Dave man you're
all in on this world economic Forum
thing like are you a little afraid
they're going to come get you and I'm
like no not really like if we're at the
point
where if you speak poorly about the
world economic Forum Stooges and they
literally can come get you whatever that
means then we've lost already so we may
as well be all in on this thing right so
we're just gonna keep going and I think
what we're going to try to do for you
today because you know I like laying out
a case what we're going to try to do
today is we will get to a whole bunch of
stuff that's happening
at the world economic forum and some
actual journalism Believe It or Not
There are actual real live journalists
that have shown up to the world economic
forum and are asking these people actual
questions uh they're not journalists
from say the New York Times or
Washington Post or CNN or anything else
they're mostly independent journalists
and journalists uh from the rebel you
guys might know the rebel up in Canada
that's Ezra Levant who I've had on the
show many times Abby yemeni who's been
on the show a bunch of other guys and
there's some other independent
journalists out there that are doing the
work of actual journalists like actually
asking the people in power what the
story is so what I'm going to try to do
for you today is we'll get to that stuff
the world economic for himself but I
want to start with some domestic stuff
going on right here and how these things
are connected because they really are
connected that is the plan and before we
do it I don't want you to be nauseous
while you're watching the show so let's
talk about relief band you know is
inflation thanks to Joe Biden making you
nauseous well you've got to check out
relief band relief van is the fda's
number one cleared anti-nausea wristband
that has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
watching videos from the world economic
forum and so much more whether you need
everyday nausea relief or just an
occasional cure from nausea their
patented technology makes feeling sick a
thing of the past it's like the name
says relief bands legitimately a band
that you wear on your wrist that gives
you relief from nausea and you can
change the intensity depending on how
you're feeling to make it stronger or
weaker that means no more nausea pills
that make you groggy and exhausted
relief band's 100 drug free and
non-drowsy plus they've got an A plus
better Your Business Bureau rating and
over a hundred thousand satisfied
customers so they're a brand you can
trust and now you can use your HSA and
FSA dollars to get a relief band so if
you've got those accounts refilled put
that money to good use and fix your
nausea problem problem for good I use my
relief band when I'm driving the kids
for peace of mind so if you want the
band that actually works at relieving
your nausea check out relief bad we've
got an offer just for Reuben report
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
and you use promo code Reuben you'll
receive 20 off plus free shipping and a
no questions asked 30-day guarantee
that's reliefband.com use promo code
Reuben for 20 off plus free shipping
that's a lot of talking people okay here
we go so let's get to the domestic part
of this puzzle that I'm always talking
about there's a puzzle we're trying to
put together the puzzle includes pieces
that
our outright lies the puzzle includes
pieces that are censored bits of
information that only leak out every now
and again usually too late for anyone to
do anything the puzzle includes these
ridiculous clown politicians who lie
about everything the puzzle includes
media members of the media who lie about
everything people who obfuscate the
truth and all of that stuff so we're
gonna show you
we have to do it do we have the warning
for the people
content advisory warning what you're
about to see is pure [ __ ] that's
right we're showing you a clip from The
View I apologize in advance Eric
swalwell who is a congressman in Cali
Northern Cali he is a really not a good
person he has had relations with the
Chinese spy we know this for a fact it
has been told from the FBI to Kevin
McCarthy we'll get to more on that in
just a second uh he went on The View
yesterday to talk about Joe Biden and
these documents these classified
documents that are now leaking out all
over the place Joe Biden's home the
Biden UPenn Center they're in the garage
turns out Hunter rented the house the
Corvette the whole thing it's very weird
anyway swalwell again who has been
compromised by a Chinese spy we'll have
evidence in just a moment I went on the
view to talk about what's going on
lawyers for President Biden found more
classified documents at his home in
Delaware a special counsel has already
been assigned to the case but how
serious is this matter to you and how
serious of a problem is this for the
president anytime classified materials
are outside of what's called a secure
classified secure compartmentalized
information facility skiff is like the
Washington Insider term that's a problem
and so I think this case in special
counsel I think is absolutely
appropriate this case will hinge on his
knowledge and intent it looks like once
he was aware of this he did what I hope
everyone would do which was
get the documents back to the government
cooperate in every meaningful way I know
it's natural to compare this to what the
former president has done where it looks
like he wanted to keep the documents and
is litigating that and fighting in the
courts what worries me with President
Trump is that somebody who was willing
to leverage 350 million dollars of
taxpayer money to get dirt on his
opponent as he did with the ukrainians
if he has top secret documents in his
possession that he could leverage that
for his own benefit but again I think
treat them both the same yeah give
independent analysis and independent
scrutiny why are they so careless with
all of this I mean are we going to find
stuff that Clinton left and that Nixon
left and that Kennedy left yeah
my favorite tweet was that everyone's a
suspect Jimmy Carter is searching his
residence hoping he'll find
classified documents everyone seems to
be you know a suspect
so you guys know I like to give the
devil is due so before I rip swallow all
apart let's give him the stuff that he
was legit on that he said you should
look into both cases okay so I'll give
him that uh he said that he's fine with
the idea of a special counsel looking
into Joe Biden so okay that's pretty
good where he starts getting confused
and here's where some of the legalese uh
and this is where lawyers are going to
have to step in and Biden's going to
have lawyers As Trump has lawyers and
it's going to start getting messy he
talks about Biden's knowledge and intent
meaning that when they found out about
this as far as we know or at least the
way Biden's team is spinning it once
they found out about it that they they
did the right thing they they told the
agencies the FBI whoever it was the
intelligence agencies hey we've got
these docs you've got to deal with it
now I don't see how that gets you off
the hook these are if these are
classified documents classified
documents mean they have some
information that is seriously important
or we are told to believe that it is
seriously important information and
Biden just had these things not only at
the UPenn Center but in his clear really
unsecured garage right like the house is
nothing spectacular uh the the crackhead
son was renting the house for an obscene
amount of money it had to do with we
know the documents had to do with Russia
and Ukraine and Iran his son the
crackhead was also working for a
Ukrainian Energy company like there's a
lot of weirdness here so his knowledge
like I do believe I've said this from
the beginning and I really do believe
it's I don't think Joe Biden himself
knew that there were classified
documents bouncing around these places I
don't think so right he probably did not
he doesn't know what day it is he
doesn't know where his shoes are this is
not a man that they would let hold a
phone right so I don't think he really
knows but the intent is sort of a moot
point because somebody is going to have
to take the fall here you could say well
Joe Biden didn't have any intent to do
this okay well somebody did it so that's
why I keep saying they are going to
either take out Biden this thing will
escalate to the point where Biden will
have to be taken out or they will have
to throw somebody under the bus and
whether that's literally really a moving
guy or a house manager or somebody
somebody is going down because of this
anyway they continued so I'm giving
swalwell a little bit of credit there it
was a roughly honest assessment although
at the end there he said that Donald
Trump leveraged 350 million dollars of
taxpayer money uh to look up to
something Ukraine something something
what the high hell is he talking about
if he's talking about the Steele dossier
that Hillary funded that kind of thing
maybe there's something there but I have
literally no idea what he's talking
about no idea what he's talking about
here's uh Joy behar's uh
insightful thoughts on Kevin McCarthy
because Kevin McCarthy is going after
swalwell quite intensely because he has
had relations with the Chinese spy
coming because Kevin McCarthy has no
soul he has no ethics he has no morals
he has no spine I don't know he's a
shell of a human being in my opinion he
crawled to get this position which he
could lose like that
first off
Joy
saying the politicians have no soul
that's what I say okay so don't steal my
lines that's number one okay uh that's
number one number two he crawled to get
the position I mean they fought it out
they fought it out the Republicans
actually did something good they had a
couple days worth of public and private
fight where you could see tension within
the party the sort of trump Wing versus
the more establishment wing and the
people who want to do more
investigations versus the people that
are a little more swampy they worked it
out they got concessions it's good
that's what makes a healthy party when
people can fight things out one of the
many problems with the Democrat Party is
that they don't fight these things out
like you could say all you want about
what Rebels AOC and ilhan Omar and the
other islamist and the other one are but
they fall in line right they end up
doing what Pelosi wants because they're
not brave and they're not leaders so the
Republicans you got to give a lot of
credit to people like Lauren bobert and
Matt Gates and everything else yes
McCarthy's still the head and I
personally I think he's a decent dude
and I think he's starting to show to I
think they're starting to actually do
the right thing and it's partly because
of that fight so so Joy's comments are
are just sort of completely ridiculous
uh but swalwell is uh is making the
rounds and the reason he's making the
rounds is because they know they've got
something on swallow because a year and
a half ago literally on my show and it
wasn't the first time McCarthy had
talked about it but it was the first
time he had I think in an extended way
talked about it has said that the FBI
knows that swalwell had relations with
the Chinese spy who was Staffing interns
and other things at his office so what
does the machine do when you're a
Democrat and they know they basically
got you what does the machine do it puts
you on all the TV shows to show how
you're the victim you have to be the
victim in this thing because as you guys
know victimhood is the highest Pinnacle
of the hierarchy of lunacy that these
people operate on here is swalwell
blaming McCarthy because people are
saying mean things to him now
you were stripped of your committee's
why
oh political Vengeance uh you know Kevin
McCarthy seems to want to heat up the
leftovers of a story that goes back to
Barack Obama's first term FBI has said
three different times in a rare form
they never talk about investigations
that all I did was help them never
suspected wrongdoing today the
Washington Post fact Checker Glenn
Kessler put out a story giving McCarthy
four Pinocchio's first claims but the
consequence of his claims is just it's
not just that I'm not on the committee
he's weaponized the intelligence
committee it's that it inspires these
death threats people parrot what Kevin
McCarthy is saying when they call and
make the threats and so he knows that
we've told this to him I have told this
to him I have you know publicly
broadcast to him that when you do this
it leads to threats to me my wife our
kids recently someone said that they
were going to rape and kill my children
and they were using the language that
Kevin McCarthy was using so there is a
cost
the guy who wanted to rape and kill his
children was using Kevin McCarthy's
language Kevin McCarthy wants to rape
and kill swalwell's children okay so
what he's trying to do there is be the
victim right so he doesn't get into the
details about the affair with this
Chinese woman this Chinese spy Fang Fang
who then uh there are many photographs
of them together and everything else but
I'll tell you how you know we're going
to show you McCarthy's comments on it in
just a second but the reason you know
the story is true and I'll gladly if
they can somehow prove that it is not
true I'll gladly retract it I'll retract
it and I'll I'll say hey boy McCarthy
lied to my face you show me that it's
not true that swalwell was operating
with this Chinese spy then I would have
a great reason to go after McCarthy
because he sat in my house and told me
that he did now I'm going to show you
that video in just a second I know
you've seen it a couple times but the
reason that I believe you know it is
true is because nobody in the media
until now was talking about it so a year
and a half ago when the House minority
leader Kevin McCarthy was talking about
it you would imagine in that the media
might be interested in that the media
might be interested in going boy that
that's interesting that a House member
is saying another house member was with
the Chinese spot you might want to cover
that or now the media wouldn't want to
do that because they like the Democrats
but wouldn't you do it to take out
McCarthy right now if they knew it was
not true and McCarthy's been running
around spreading this crazy rumor about
Eric swalwell's relation with the
Chinese spot wouldn't the media do their
darndest to expose the hell out of it
they would on TV every day you would
have all the videos including the video
of my show where he's saying that the
FBI told him that he's had that swallow
was having relations with the fight just
so you could take out McCarthy the fact
that they've ignored it this whole time
actually is the proof so here's McCarthy
in his own words and you can decide
whether McCarthy is an absolute liar or
whether swallow well is a liar but the
fact that the media buried it for a year
and a half pretty much tells you what
the answer is didn't swallow sleep with
the Chinese spy or something I mean yes
why okay that's a good question well we
know publicly a Chinese spy and also
remember Senator Feinstein we found out
later the driver of more than 10 years
was a Chinese spy in Silicon Valley
there have been in pictures together
this woman a Chinese spy creates a
relationship with swallowing things in
the city council
he runs for Congress
she helps she puts interns in his office
do you know how difficult it is to get
on the Intel committee
when suavel was put on the Intel
committee they were in the minority so
they had some fewer seats he was a
sophomore getting partner on the Intel
committee he's kept on the Intel
committee now you know this you put him
on you did not know now you know as a
leader
okay if swallow was in the private
sector he could not get a security
clearance
because he had a relationship with a spy
but it only in America can he be given
the Intel committee where he knows all
the secrets
but there's 200 other Democrats who are
qualified to be on that slot and she
keeps appointing what I know with what
the FBI told me
he should never be on Intel and Pelosi
reappointed an Intel
I don't understand this did you have you
said this to her yes
but this is worse I brought a motion to
the floor
to remove him from Intel put another
Democrat on the Democrats all defended
so do you see why I'm saying this story
has to be true that is a year and a half
ago a year and a half ago you've got
McCarthy saying that Not only was did
the FBI tell him that swallow well is
having these relations with the Chinese
spy who helped staff his office but also
that Dianne Feinstein from California
that she had a driver for 10 years who
was a Chinese spy and that Nancy Pelosi
knew it those are seriously high level
accusations so if they were lies if they
were completely made up would the
mainstream media be being quiet about it
quiet about it right of course they
wouldn't they would be using the lies
the obvious lies they would get all
their FBI people out there and 27 FBI
agents and intelligence people signed a
document saying that McCarthy's a liar
but they haven't done any of that they
have buried the story and now now that
McCarthy is in charge McCarthy did the
right thing of course you're going to
take swalwell off the intelligence
Community uh the intelligence Committee
of course you're going gonna do that
absolutely so swalwell who is having
whatever these relations are has had
whatever relations he's had with this
Chinese spy uh what does he think the
real threat to U.S national security is
it's not Chinese spies in our congress
people's office it's well of course the
Republicans
what you're seeing here is a party that
barely won the house lost the Senate
Kevin McCarthy took 15 votes you know to
become speaker he doesn't have political
Capital he has a political deficit he's
not delivering on inflation gas grocery
costs Health Care border crime all the
things he told the voters he would
deliver on they have created a law firm
instruction LLC and they're just going
to carry out Donald Trump's grievances
talk about not reading the room or the
country
you got to understand this he's on The
View he's on CNN he's on MSNBC he's a
victim Kevin McCarthy's coming after me
right all this stuff and then every
there were several lies in there first
off the Republicans didn't lose the
Senate the Republicans didn't have the
Senate so they didn't just lose the
Senate they did win the house but they
didn't lose the Senate that's number one
and then he's saying well well the
Republicans aren't uh delivering on
inflation gas border crime etc etc uh
you know the guy just got the job a week
ago about 10 days ago and they actually
are starting to do a whole bunch of
stuff and it is your guy if you're upset
Eric swalwell about inflation gas border
crime uh it's your guy mentally
compromised Joe Biden that's in charge
of the country right now right it's your
team that has the Senate it's your team
that had the Congress so you're very
upset that in seven days Kevin McCarthy
hasn't done absolutely everything
possible and then of course you know
that that in essence half the countries
amongst a bunch of insurrectionists so
he can say that about us all the time
right we're all a bunch of insurrection
were a bunch of white supremacists and
we hate and this guy's just if you if
you look at this guy's Twitter I mean he
says the worst things constantly about
half the country so somehow when he gets
a death threat uh and somebody wants to
somebody says they want to do something
horrible to his child that's Kevin
McCarthy's fault but when he says all
these horrible things about us I mean
it's this thing with irony and double
standards you guys get it uh so who is
the real threat is it the January 6th
insurrectionists who didn't bring any
weapons and had no plans or anything
like that or is it uh say congress
people involved with Chinese spies is it
the people who misplace or
don't know what the hell they're doing
with classified documents and how is
this all related to everything I've been
talking about all all week with the
world economic Forum well it's all
related of course to National Security
and our ability to be an actual
independent nation which is the complete
reverse of what the people at the world
economic Forum want us to be so one of
the other things happening right now is
that it is very bizarre but the truth is
a slow motion pill it's a Time released
pill these days so what's happening
right now on mainstream media is they're
finally starting to catch on that
something might be brewing with this
Biden scandal okay the Biden scandal is
all over the place because not only is
it about these classified documents but
also that at as he was vice president
that Hunter was getting jobs with the
ukrainians that he didn't
uh wasn't qualified for and that Biden
might have been compromised himself so
here's a little bit uh from CNN from CNN
believe it or not on that
a CNN review of the laptop data as well
as other public material shows that Joe
Biden did in Iraq with some of his son's
Associates while serving as vice
president though it's unclear exactly
what was discussed one example the
Republican site Miguel Aleman magnani a
Mexican businessman and Son of the
former president who Hunter was trying
to woo in 2014
and his dad were photographed at the
White House with then Vice President
Biden in a later email Hunter Biden
reminds alimony magnani of the favors
he's done for him we have been talking
about business deals and Partnerships
for seven years I have brought every
single person you have ever asked me to
bring to the effing White House and the
vice president's house and the
inauguration Hunter Biden bluntly
acknowledged the power of the Biden name
in a memoir writing that the Ukrainian
Energy company barisma which put him on
its board considered my last name gold I
don't think that there's a lot of things
that would have happened my life that
that if my last name wasn't five
oh [ __ ] Sherlock uh because whoever was
selling you the crack probably wouldn't
have marked it up but they mark up crack
for a Biden that's what I've heard
that's what I've heard on the street
um so you see something's happening here
something's happening here all of us
that have been talking about this level
of corruption and obviously something
involving his son and barisma and the
laptop
something's going on now where it's
reaching mainstream that may just be
because they feel that the machine just
feels we're done with Biden he got us he
beat Trump got us through the midterms
we got to get rid of this guy now he
served his purpose and he is the
ultimate type of swamp creature right he
has been in public office for I think 48
years at this point and now they're
ready to put him out to pastor but it's
not just his relationship with Hunter
Biden that's the problem here even his
own brother his Joe Biden's brother's
business dealings are related to Joe and
the family name and all that stuff
Joe Biden's Brothers have repeatedly
referenced him in their private dealings
Frank Biden a developer of for-profit
charter schools has invoked his brother
in trying to convince local officials to
approve his projects like in Sunrise
Florida where he told the city in 2015
to trust his Venture not because of
Frank
but because of the honor of being the
brother of a guy I think we all know and
love in 2021 at a gathering of medical
professionals he made this pledge
I have as a result of the privilege of
being associated with with my brother
Joey and I'll do everything in my power
to support you to get the job done to
get federal dollars to
search
oh the president's brother was going to
do everything he could to get federal
dollars for people that were connected
to him through business does that sound
like it might be some sort of shady
thing do you think if that certain
orange Man's brother had done that sort
of thing that people might be looking
into that do you think that if the
orange man's son was a crack addict that
people might be looking into that do you
think there might be something here I
think you think what I'm thinking and
it's something there's something here
indeed uh the best part of that is that
his brother Frank I did not know this
until we played that video uh his
brother Frank does for-profit charter
schools which is something that the
Democrats hate right the Democrats love
Public Schools shitty ass gonna make
your child stupid Public Schools they
hate
Charter Schools they hate private
schools well they hate them not for
their own children they hate them for
your children that's the difference
anyway very interesting but this thing
is blowing up all over the place and
again you are now going to see us we're
doing the dance throughout the show
today how are you linking this to the
world economic Forum a deeply
compromised American Administration
clearly and the media that can is
running out of room to cover for it
right that's the only reason CNN times
and these things they only finally get
to the answer when they have absolutely
no choice because the truth the truth
actually cannot be stopped the truth is
just out there and eventually it does
burst forth one way or another thank God
so as this is all coming out uh people
are starting to ask other politicians
about what's going on one of the
politicians I don't know if you've heard
about this guy we've got this guy down
in Florida Rhonda said this is doing a
fine job he was asked about what's going
on with Joe Biden and actually his uh
his team just released a new Instagram
account it's called is it team Ron
DeSantis oh sorry no it's a DeSantis war
room and they put this video up this is
DeSantis being asked about the Biden doc
scandal
it's on not necessarily related to this
but um obviously we're hearing in the
news about the documents that's going on
with uh President Biden wanted to get
your thoughts on that
so the questions about uh Biden's
documents and um
you know look he said that it was
incredibly Reckless to have classified
he said all this stuff you know on 60
Minutes and um you know now you find out
he had him stashed behind his Corvette
at his house that Hunter had access to
which is definitely a security risk in
my book and so I think it just shows you
um you know the what some of these folks
do you know they had all this stuff to
say now they're acting like you know
this this is something like it's not a
big deal what's good for the goose is
good for the gander you can't have two
different sets of rules based on your
political party
you can't even though the mainstream
would love that we do right they always
have two sets of rules so everything
that Santa said there was right right
like obviously the garage was not secure
Biden said the complete reverse when
this was about Trump and the
incompetence of trump to do this and all
that of course as you guys know the
president does have a right to
declassify documents the vice president
which is what Joe Biden was at the time
of these docs does not have to do that
but as long as we're in Florida for a
second grant me a little bit of a leash
here and DeSantis continued to talk
about some of the great things that are
happening right here in the independent
free autonomous state known as Florida
we're going to do more uh tax relief in
the upcoming legislative session I've
mentioned some of this stuff in the fall
about how we're going to make basically
raising kids tax-free no tax on diapers
wipes children's clothes strollers cribs
none of that stuff can be too late for
me and my and my wife and our kids there
getting you know five four and and two
now but for for younger families be able
to do it it's going to be really really
important because again those are things
you just have to buy you got to buy the
diapers you got to buy these things so
that's going to save families a lot of
money yeah we may even say no tax on gas
stoves coming up this year we'll do that
that's fine with me I want you to be
able to have a choice
it really is so great first off I'd like
to personally thank the governor because
as a parent of two young children
there's a lot of diapers in this house
and I guess we'll be saving a little
money on diapers unfortunately we bought
all the cribs and strollers already so
we got on that one but okay fine uh but
the thing there at the end about the gas
stoves it's like he's just responding to
the lunacy of these people and now if
you want to buy a gas stove in Florida
it'll be a little bit cheaper so how am
I linking this all okay we've got the
incompetence of the administration the
people like swalwell who cover up for it
in the media who covers up for them uh
and then you sh we we're showing you
some competent people right some people
that are actually telling you the truth
and who are doing good work on the
ground how am I linking that to the
world economic forum and everything else
I think you'll start seeing what we're
doing here in essence what they fear
most is the individual what they fear
most are elected officials and and you
and me regular people who will stand up
against them and do the right thing and
that is what's happening right here so
when you get a guy who's doing the right
thing what does the machine do the
machine brings on a bunch of hacks to
try to take that person out so here is
Democrat activist Jake Tapper on CNN and
he brought on Maryland governor Larry
Hogan now Larry Hogan is if you listen
to the mainstream media if you listen to
the corporate press I know you guys
don't but if you listen to them this is
one of the guys that they really think
will be a great Republican and anytime
that the mainstream media tells you that
a republican is great then he's going to
be the guy and all that stuff that means
he's nothing right Liz Cheney think of
this guy as sort of a Liz Cheney there
are no Republicans that like him so he
gets on CNN all the time so here is
former Maryland governor Larry Hogan on
Democrat activist Jake Tapper show on
fake news CNN going after Ron DeSantis
Governor Ron DeSantis is often cited by
conservative Republicans as somebody
they might want to see run for president
you've called him an important voice one
of the important voices for the party do
you think he would be good at what
you're talking about in terms of
reaching out to people in the middle
well he hasn't done it so far I mean
he's done a really good job of getting
on Fox News and he's capturing a lot of
attention but he certainly hasn't done
it the way Charlie Baker and Phil Scott
and I have I mean I you know we we're a
consistently the most highest job
approval in the country and I think
DeSantis is down around 30th Place among
Governors is that because he's too
focused on the base too focused on red
meat issues I just think that he is
focused on the base and he's he's doing
pretty well with the base but he's going
to have to figure out a way if he if he
wants to have a political future Beyond
Florida to appeal
I mean it's so extraordinary once you
see as I always say like once you see it
you can never unsee it so you need to
understand Larry Hogan's running for
president he has literally no support
he'll be in and out over overnight but
the media will prop him up because he'll
go after the guy that's the real threat
I bet he sits there with a straight face
and oh and I'm the guy me and Charlie
Charlie Baker I was going to say Charlie
Parker the great jazz musician were the
guys that are the crossover people okay
it's so patently ridiculous and just on
its face Rhonda said it's just one in
perhaps the biggest Landslide one of the
biggest landsides in American political
history he took a state that was very
very purple because it was always
flipping between red and blue and now
they have super majorities the
Republicans he won by 20 points there he
turned uh districts like Miami-Dade red
when they are The Bluest blue
strongholds ever he has all of the
independence he has all of the new
refugees you don't even have to hear me
say that just look at the numbers these
people didn't appear out of nowhere on
top of the fact that I can tell you as
as someone that's been here for a year I
go all over this state I do tons of
events everywhere I have talked to
hundreds if not thousands of people who
are telling me that they are former
Democrats who are now here because of
Freedom thanks to what Geron DeSantis is
doing I myself
I'm a first time registered Republican
because of Ron DeSantis and what the
good people of Florida have been doing
so you need to just understand the
reason I'm showing you that is that's
what they do when you get someone who
will stand up for America who will stand
up for the Constitution who will stand
up for your right to live as you see fit
the machine
CNN Jake Tapper Larry Hogan all of the
hacks will come out of nowhere and try
to take them out this guy has no support
Charlie Baker has no support but the
machine just like they did with Liz
Cheney who then lost by 40 points to
Harriet Hageman right but they loved her
in her January 6th commission and all of
that stuff so that's why they're trying
to take this guy out because what the
machine wants to do is they want to take
out anyone who's a threat to the
globalist order that is absolutely the
truth and the Democrats and the media
are in it with them so now let's get to
the world economic forum and what's
going on over there these people they
are meeting they are eating filet mignon
and foie gras and all of this fancy
stuff while saying you're not going to
eat meat they're flying in their private
jets and a whole bunch more uh here is
uh Pfizer CEO Albert borla this is a man
who has lied about everything for the
last three years efficacy of vaccines uh
had pushed mandates he has been
connected to all of the governments that
did all of the bad stuff but here he is
talking about how the vaccines uh there
was skepticism around the vaccines
because everything became politicized
the first year of the pandemic we
produced three billion doses of a
vaccine that we never had manufactured
before but if you ask me what was the
biggest challenge I think was the
political challenge
I think the vaccines the covet and the
ability to deliver not vaccine so then
after we delivered the ability to use
them or not became severely politicized
and became a political statement if you
are wearing a mask or not
became a political statement if you
believe you will have a vaccine or not
and after we had the vaccine it became a
political statement if you believe it
works or not and then we went to more
extremes if you believe that covet
existed or not all of these were
constantly on our way and you know I'm a
businessman I'm a scientist I'm not a
politician
to be in the same is the same for all of
my peers right the the head of modernity
that they were trying to do the same and
that we found it the most challenging of
all the tasks and that continued after
the vaccine as you know
governments everybody was scared at that
time
you see how you the individual are the
biggest problem for these people
you are the Cog in the machine that they
don't like right you because you make
things politicized when they try to
inject you with things and you say I
would prefer not to be injected with
your thing they don't like that I would
prefer to leave my house every now and
again they don't like that I'd prefer to
go to Grandma's funeral they don't like
that so things became politicized I
don't want to wear a chin napkin on my
face all day they don't like that so do
you see what they try to it all became
politicized I'm a businessman I'm a
scientist now he never references the
fact that the vaccines don't work or
anything else because that would be a
problem we should have just bowed to him
but us the peons using our powers of
politicization we are the true bad guys
in this uh let's flash back because here
is Pfizer CEO Albert borla in February
of 2021 telling Lester Holt on NBC uh
that the vaccine protects against
transmission he's a little confused and
as we know that did not turn out to be
true doctor people get these
vaccinations with obviously the hope
that they won't die from this disease
and they won't get horribly sick but
they also want a sense of freedom and
and right now we're being told you got
to still wear the mask because of the
possibility you could still infect
others what do the data show you uh is
it likely that you could still infect
others even after two doses
again it's something that needs to be
confirmed and the real world data that
you are getting from Israel and other
studies will help us understand this
better I think it is a
I'm almost certain but the data needs to
to provide that there will be a high
degree of protection against
transmission as well but there are a lot
of indications right now that uh are
telling us that there is uh uh a
protection against uh transmission
no liar fraud criminal uh it did not
stop transmission and in many cases it
now seems that people who are vaxed are
getting coveted even more and in some
cases it seems like vaxed people are
getting sicker even more so that was
basically a year ago right now it was
February of 2021 lying just lying and
you can see it there at the end he
didn't even have the data yet but I feel
pretty good about what's going to happen
here and it was all a lie but what was
also a lie is the way they sold it all
in the first place so we've shown you
some versions of compilations like this
a couple times before here's just a
general compilation of people lying
about what the vaccine is going to do
during 2021 we should be able to
manufacture a lot of vaccines and and
That vaccine a key goal is to stop the
transmission to get the immunity levels
up so that you get almost no almost no
uh infection going on whatsoever we can
kind of almost see the end we're
vaccinating so very fast our data from
the CDC 's today so
that people do not carry the virus don't
get sick now we know that the vaccines
work well enough that the virus stops
with every vaccinated person a
vaccinated person gets exposed to the
virus
the virus does not infect them the virus
cannot then use that person to go
anywhere else it cannot use a vaccinated
person as a host to go get more people
that means the vaccines will get us to
the end of this fully vaccinated people
are at a very very low risk of getting
covet 19.
therefore if you've been fully
vaccinated you no longer need to wear a
mask when people are vaccinated they can
feel safe that they are not going to get
infected so we could have played that
all day long you know there's a million
versions of that note that none of those
people were fired nobody's been taken
into a room and smacked on the wrist
nothing has happened to any of these
people Phoenix just reminded me when we
went to the uh the capitol about two
months ago right after the election we
actually literally walked past wolenski
in the hall like my our arms almost
touched and I'm telling you she comes
off like an alien there was something
about her body that was like remember in
uh uh Men In Black when the when the
alien rips the guy's body open and lives
inside him like the Cockroach man like
that she I think she might be well all
I'm saying is I think they might have
taken out the actual wilensky some sort
of alien ripped her soul out and now
there's an alien living in her body I
I'm just saying that's possible this
information according to YouTube uh
anyway the point is they lied about
everything the [ __ ] does not work it
basically never worked they probably
knew it the entire time but what happens
you don't get fired you just keep
sending more nonsense out to the rest of
us so now here's borla yesterday at the
wef and they're making more vaccines and
this time they're going to include the
flu in it where are you in development
because I know I think that's what you
originally do with Beyond Tech you were
developing mRNA for flu where are you on
a flu vaccine based on mRNA oh beside
this running they have completely
recruited we are waiting for cases as
they accumulate means that people have
been vaccinated good Placebo vaccine and
then the disease some of them will get
disease and then we are waiting to
unblind the data to see what is coming I
think we'll come in the this year that's
what I was going to ask I mean you can't
guarantee a timeline depending on the
clinical trial no because you best guess
what would you think I think by the
first half of the year maybe first half
of the year yeah right wow and so how
far are we away from one vaccine that's
both covered and flu together
and if we have a flu already we started
experiments to combine the two so that
we don't lose time again uh I think
we'll come more or less all together if
it is successful
there is any justice in this world that
journalist from Bloomberg that's what
the step and repeat behind him said that
journalist should be fired immediately
that's not that's not a journalist a
journalist would have looked that guy in
the eye and said hey your [ __ ] doesn't
work he wouldn't have been like oh your
coveted vaccines that's really great can
you get us a flu vaccine too he would
have been like hey but you promised us
all the stuff and it didn't work like
like it's just extraordinary and that
this guy can sit there with a straight
face knowing that the covid vaccine
failed and now they want a super vaccine
for flu and covet we are at the
beginning of I Am Legend people and all
of them are going to turn into zombies
so we're going to have zombies wandering
the streets walensky's an alien you get
the point so what do you do what do you
do you keep pushing back not only do you
do Stateside what DeSantis is doing
right here but then there are actual
journalists I this is so spectacular
this is so absolutely spectacular Rebel
news which is up in Canada it's one of
the non-state funded journalist outfits
and I can actually say journalists
without going like this up in Canada
they do great great work ezrael Levant
who has been on the show many times and
he's he's a friend of mine and a great
guy he is out there with the team in
Davos on the ground asking these guys
questions here's Avi yemeni who's one of
the guys at Rebel uh basically hunting
down borla and watch journalism in
action this is journalism completely uh
against what we just saw with that
Bloomberg hack Mr borla can I ask you
how did you know that the vaccines
didn't stop transmission how long did
you know that without saying it publicly
thank you very much I'm sorry to that
question
I mean we we now know that the vaccines
didn't stop transmission but why did you
keep it secret
you said it was 100 effective then 90
then 80 then 70 but we now know that the
vaccines do not trans stop transmission
why did you keep that secret have a nice
day I won't have a nice day until I know
the answer why did you keep it a secret
that your vaccine
did not stop transmission
is it time to apologize to the world sir
to give refunds back to the countries
that poured all their money into your
vaccine that doesn't work your
ineffective vaccine
are you not ashamed of what you've done
in the last couple of years Jeopardy
apologies to the public sir
okay that's it those are great people
right there so I want to give credit to
Ezra Levant of course who was asking the
initial questions and that's Abby yemeni
who's doing the follow-up there you know
what's so interesting too so this borla
guy can go on these ridiculous corporate
press things and just spread more
nonsense and he has these these fake
hack journalists who sit there and don't
acknowledge anything bad that happened
but oh but you can do more and we can
give you more of our attention and and
and money and pay and all of that stuff
and are literally our bodies
if borla believed in anything he has
sold to us in these last three years why
wouldn't he have just stopped for one
second like if you if you created a
product a vaccine that is working that
is doing anything remotely close to what
you said why wouldn't he have just
stopped for one second and said uh
thanks for the question Ezra that's
actually pretty easy uh the efficacy is
this uh it was a little bit off perhaps
what we thought it was going to be but
but he can't he can't so that's actual
journalism and if you want to see even
more journalism this is absolutely
wonderful I saw this yesterday a
Japanese independent journalist her name
is masoko masako ganaha I hope I
pronounced that right she actually
confronted Palpatine himself that's
right shiv Palpatine Klaus Schwab was
wandering around Davos and she went up
to him this is just beautiful
are you from Japan yeah and may I ask
you for a comment no we're on our way
we're on our way to the next thing we're
a bit late but thank you thank you I
think we're gonna we're gonna Rush
actually but thank you thanks very much
which which media are you always I am an
independent journalist yeah no thank you
thank you
it's the face of evil and did you get
that part of the end which journalist uh
which are you with right and when she
says I'm an independent journalist
that's when he freaks out because he
knows if she's a corporate journalist if
she had said I'm with Bloomberg well
you're good to go you're not going to
ask a question you're going to prop me
up and I'm an independent journalist I
might ask you something true and these
people cannot be asked anything true
they can only be sucked off but the
sucking must stop uh So speaking of
Klaus Schwab uh one of the things that
he has done quite effectively and you do
have to give the devil his due he has
sent his minions Across the Western
World and he has sent people who learn
his globalist ideas to places like
Canada with Justin Trudeau and places
like New Zealand with prime minister
Jacinda adern she is the woman who uh
you may remember the video at the height
of kovid said do not believe anything
unless we tell it to you we the
government uh anyway here's a little
video of her she's a wef stooge here's a
little video of her past coveted
Authority arianism and you'll you'll see
why we're showing you this in just a sec
David St Moore has met with some of the
so-called leadership of this protest do
you think that emboldens the protesters
and do you think it's a responsible
thing to do no I don't think it was a
responsible thing to do for a party that
purports to be the champion of Law and
Order or indeed businesses to meet with
those who are obstructing wellingtonians
from going about their everyday lives
bullying and harassing people who are
trying to go to school or work
everything's been really good yeah and
people are behaving themselves yep
everything's looking really good from
what we've seen yeah caring for each
other the vibe is very is very nice
bullying and harassing people who are
trying to go to school or work I trusted
government and then I was supposed to
take this because I'm losing my job if
we weren't coerced and brainwashed into
getting these vaccines he could still be
alive
if we weren't forced into making a
choice between our jobs incomes and
livelihoods
he could still be alive
bullying and harassing people if you
want summer
if you want to go to bars and
restaurants get vaccinated if you want
to get a haircut get vaccinated bullying
and harassing people if you want to go
to a concert or a festival get
vaccinated if you want to go to a gym or
a sports event get vaccinated
obstructing wellingtonians from going
about their everyday lives if you are
not vaccinated there will be everyday
things you will miss out on
she is the face of evil just like Klaus
Schwab is the face of evil and Justin
Trudeau is the face of evil with her uh
you could see it you you could see the
evil that has go Google this after the
show find videos and images of her from
five years ago to now they have sucked
the soul out of this woman's body and
that's why she looks like the face of
death she looks like the Grim Reaper
um we have to finish show a little bit
quicker today because I got a couple
things going on so I want to do this
fairly quickly uh here she is this short
video talking about two classes of
citizens that they were going to have in
New Zealand
so you basically said this is going to
be like well it's almost like you
probably don't see like this the two
different classes of people if you're
vaccinated or if you're unvaccided you
have all these rights if you are
vaccinated that is what it is so yep yep
showing you this I'm showing you this
because this woman who all of her
actions are very much like Justin
Trudeau's right he was calling all of
the people who were against his mandates
all of the worst things in the world she
wanted in a place like New Zealand
people to be backs to be at outdoor
concerts and everything else well
something has happened people and here's
the good Twist on this thing she
announced her resignation last night
enough people are stepping up people are
not swallowing the nonsense anymore and
this this Joy Behar you think Kevin
McCarthy's soulless no no this soulless
woman who who abused her own citizens
abused her power she's now stepping down
and so today I'm announcing that I will
not be seeking re-election
and then my team as prime minister will
conclude no later than the 7th of
February
see the pain on her face she either
knows that she sold her soul or she
knows she's done something evil or she
knows that people died on her watch or
something uh here's what the meme makers
of the internet did with that clip
and so today I'm announcing that I will
not be seeking re-election
and the my tourist prime minister will
conclude no later than the 7th of
February
getting rid of these people I don't know
exactly what's going on there but she's
gone Trudeau will be gone soon enough
there are real journalists like Ezra
Levant and Avi yemeni and people at the
rebel that are doing the work while the
corporate media fails us at every level
and it carries water and runs cover for
these people I will not stop I hope you
will not stop we've got a post game show
coming up right now at
reubenreport.locals.com and I'll see the
rest of you tomorrow
we need to scale up climate Finance but
we need desperately to scale down
anti-climate Finance only thing you need
to study is your ass I got a big ass
your mama got a big head you would do
have big ass enough already enough
babies got a little gears we are still
subsidizing the burning of fossil fuels
yeah the all I'm trying to see is that
scientific breakthroughs are occurring
all the time and the only thing about
the great dude is your ass about to
break through a seat of your pants and
we need to rein them the anti-climate
activities of the fossil ends dude wait
get hit there get in shape get everybody
looking all anorexia talking about that
here today I know what healthy is we
need new leadership at the World Bank
you can sew up your stomach and your
[ __ ] you will always be back
[Music]